I hate to start out on such a sophomoric
note but that is a literal butt crack
easy Darwin reference is easy movie
things a Breaking Bad reference will buy
in some early subconscious goodwill and
you know what movie is right I bought a
ticket solely because Walter White was
in this and if you've seen this movie
you know why this is still a sin it's a
little-known hollywood rule that you
can't make a godzilla movie without
putting some generic old timey war
footage behind the opening credits
discount in gen Ken Watanabe is in this
movie but I'm not sure he's ever really
into this movie character has a pocket
watch that is super important to them
cliche you gotta see this cliche Looby
combines aliens in Jurassic Park forces
us to realize that this is like the 33rd
Godzilla movie ever made and well
goddamn it it's probably just the wind
oh yeah we are about to see some
Godzilla oh this room is an orgy of
evidence that this kid plays with toys
in a manner that will be aesthetically
pleasing to a cinematic tracking shot
movie lingers on a poster of primary
villains is foreshadowing but characters
live in a world where creatures like
this are documented fact it's like a
lingering shot of a poster depicting
death and taxes respect and honor with
all of that that's racist all right
that's my man Bryan Cranston he's the
same needle of this movie he's gonna
guide us all the way through to the end
because he's awesome I sure hope the
filmmakers don't pull the rug out from
under me on this prediction so when we
get there don't even bother coming up
just grab a team and go down to level 5
death sentence all right
that is exactly what Juliette Binoche
says to me in my recurring dream keep
the doors open my wife Estelle
don't do the thing because the someone
is still in there cliche thankfully for
her in the audience the radiation that
is fast approaching her is doing so in a
visible cloud-based form extra layer of
door security arrives super late so that
Joe and Sandra can say goodbye heroic
teacher is the first one out when it
comes to the classroom evacuation and
leaves an army of abandoned children in
her wake Elizabeth Olson isn't my army
wife in this scene ringing phone
prevents Elizabeth Olsen from answering
yes to the question have you driven a
Ford lately
you can't bury this in the past wait
what not only is Ford completely
reversing his position after a terrible
speech and deciding to help his father
but dude you are in the US military and
you're about to go break the law in
Japan think about your career character
pulses mask off because air is more
likely than not to be breathable cliche
it's clean I know why didn't you do the
take off the mask experiment a few days
ago when you were in the quarantine zone
did they stop you before you could enter
and arrest you cuz then how did you
manage to get in with ease in broad
daylight this time Mothra reference
serves to remind you that Mothra will be
playing the aptly named sir not
appearing in this film floppy disks
stacked in full view of surrounding
destruction managed to survive extremely
likely weather warping and other
calamities for 15 years last time they
just arrested him this time let's drive
him further into the quarantine zone to
headquarters and let him see everything
going on one of them says he used to
work here doctor why didn't he say that
the last time he was arrested or if he
did why didn't you care then well you
see in 1999 there were floppy disks that
stored data instead of the flash drives
and we use now you need an older
computer with a floppy disk drive to
read them of course you likely lived in
1999 so you probably know that it's not
transform and you Joe has been obsessed
with this for years but hasn't dr.
Serizawa also been studying this for at
least 15 years and with way more
information than Joe got to work with
how did he not figure that out it's done
video I certainly hope so
we're talking 15 in years here theory
it's almost like we've been through this
before it's almost like the first 30
minutes of this movie didn't really
matter we don't know what the hell could
hatch out of this thing so the brilliant
solution is a web of cables tangling
that's the solution what could possibly
go wrong and what no Yeager's you had 15
years to build a Jaeger or plant a bomb
under it instead this team of scientists
fits the time away on Jager bombs it
takes 35 minutes for Godzilla to show up
in up Hey that is not even Godzilla he's
still locked in the police fan they just
abandon prisoners in times of crisis man
I hope they do that thing where some
monster related action bullshit somehow
opens the doors to let him out without
killing him hey Ron Jesus in the name of
a cool shot directors keep having the
main character stand still in awe at the
sight of things that would cause real
people to be Fred Flintstone in the hell
out of here Ford falls backwards back
into the police van which is probably a
good idea since he's impossible to kill
while inside it I'm not sure why he's
putting on the mask but ensures nice of
the military police to have lift up with
him in the back of the van
instead of confiscating it area is he's
a rock man I can't wait until the end of
this movie and he's standing on top of
one of these creatures heads and
proclaiming victory
let's move he's gonna ride that bryan
cranston turning the whole way i can
feel it is he dead
actually yes he is but the movie wants
to wait to reveal that for some reason
robbing us of any actual cool emotional
death moment and instead replacing it
with a zipping up the body bank shot as
the reveal because i have no fucking
idea cmp disruption to create havoc with
our radar and satellite feeds and reduce
us for the moment to a strictly visual
pursuit well isn't that convenient to
the runtime of this movie okay movie can
handle another major character actor as
long as bryan cranston is still there at
the end
what a fucking tragic waste of bryan
cranston who only kills for sport this
historical footage contains more
godzilla than the actual movie we call
him roll credits we're monitoring all
known sites but if we don't find it soon
i don't know if one word maybe if you
let her finish she'd tell you this wife
who was worried sick about her maybe
dead husband would not hurt her damn
phone on vibrate you a movie and I'd
probably let this LG product place would
go without a sin if it wasn't for that
stupid ask her phone in case you
confused it with Honolulu Afghanistan
unsupervised bastard plot kid plots to
bastard this movie with his lack of
supervision will be about big lizards
can't resist using a little lizard in an
establishing shot cliche hell more
secrets
see tech astronomy it actually ends up
taking 55 minutes half the movie before
Godzilla himself even shows up and when
he finally does you'll Square for a
moment you're actually watching the 1998
Godzilla Godzilla it's plain enough to
swim under the ship so that the main
character doesn't die too soon but these
other boats oh let's throw a dog in
peril in here suddenly and randomly
people love that Godzilla will now be
the hero of the story after drowning
countless Hawaiians and destroying the
city Muto waits until the lights come on
to make any noises or take
earth-shattering steps because this mute
o has an excellent sense of dramatic
timing
Mido decides not to use its EMP when
threatened this time I mean why bother
movie instantly makes itself unavailable
for in-flight viewing with nightmare
Airport explosion sequence also main
character and current main antagonist
Muto and Godzilla all end up at the
Hawaii Airport at the same damn time
even though the Muto could fly and Ford
took a ship and then a helicopter to get
there
Domino explosions holy Sh
even Liam Neeson just pissed himself
remove two sins wait did you just cut
away from the action just as Godzilla
showed up the fuck movie Chiefs out and
puts all the good Godzilla action into a
fake TV news broadcast instead of
showing it to us regular style this is
what happens when you hire a guy famous
for making a movie called monsters that
basically doesn't have any monsters in
it only people this kid wanders away
because Godzilla movie is more
interested in generic civilian drama
than actual Godzilla stuff also movie
suddenly turns into Minority Report
that's the weird twist they put in this
Godzilla movie so ended the saga of the
bullshit no one Eltham Utley cared about
anyway but thanks for adding seven
minutes of runtime you little fucker
plot the speed and heading of these
things isn't that what you were just
talking about simulations uploaded
satellite track from containers what's
this line supposed to go before that
kind of put on foot soldiers discover
this destroyed vault at the exact time
as the helicopters circling the mountain
I'll tell you how because the director
had an idea for a cool shot okay so this
asshole needs nuclear fuel to survive
and now needs to mate with the other
mute oh so why bigges why the hell does
this creature need to destroy Vegas now
there's nothing for here and it could
just go around right is there an
inherent need for the mute Oh to just
destroy cities for no reason the Mito
has been around long enough to get on
the local news but word somehow didn't
travel to this casino via Twitter
cellphone calls police warning screaming
assholes from the street or anything
that would normally happen in a
situation like this that's what you get
for gambling you bunch of degenerates
believe it or not on the whole Vegas
actually still made money on this day
also once again movie delights in
showing us the destruction but almost
none of the action that created it why
does he swim so slowly that slow ass
aircraft carriers can keep up with him
it's Godzilla
a slacker current tracking models
indicate that all three targets are
converging here San Francisco Bay
finally someone's gonna take care of the
homeless problem in San Francisco also
the Muto's want a bang and they need
nuclear energy to make a child the
fuckers in San Francisco Bay that makes
this possible or is it just the most
romantic place to do this Yes Doctor
goes you know maybe the answer oh good
he's here to restore balance dude you
didn't even know about electromagnetic
pulses before Bryan Cranston came on the
scene now you know with certainty what
Godzilla's motives are 19:45 parish in
Hiroshima shaming that means you were
born by August 6 1945 then right because
your dad can't have died before he
provided the sperm portion of you so
that makes you in this modern set movie
a minimum was 69 years old which is
bullshit
the other possibility is that the
biggest tragedy that happened to his
father was that his watch stopped Oh
shouting military guy is a wealth of
information for the movies primary I
guess hero he's in the movie alone I
suppose also what amazing timing that
wants to get there just as the train
stopped and then be able to get on that
train back to San Francisco all action
movies must have a pretty girl
regardless of story importance end of
discussion
it's 2014 this TV and these VHS tapes
are a sin I completely agree sir
unnecessary agreement confirmation of
mandatory orders how do you not know
this information already this phone
thing is filled with radioactive waste
and you have satellites and radar and
all sorts of and it's huge replied that
before megatons not kilotons nothing can
withstand that blast
I really don't doubt the US military
would still think modern bombs would
kill these things but it was a little
wary that the bomb back then didn't even
put a scratch on Godzilla
what the hell is this asshole doing this
is the problem with the needs nuclear
waste to survive trait she has no reason
to stop pray or hide or be a horror
movie villain she should just constantly
be moving and looking for that sweet ass
yeah like you give a about a train horn
is it wrong that this makes me horny we
interrupt this Godzilla movie to bring
you stand by me you know this whole idea
about luring the mute out of the water
by putting the nuclear weapons in the
ocean definitely had one flaw if the
weapons are so irresistible then
obviously the mera would be able to
detect an derail the train carrying the
weapons before we got to San Francisco I
don't know why they didn't just fly
there and get them there faster here's
your second look at Godzilla in this
movie
yep he's still useless let's go now Rena
sir Godzilla what's the military tailing
for half the Pacific Ocean before
finally burning rubber unkillable
character is unkillable
you gotta love that the muna left one
nuke relatively unharmed despite eating
the entire Train the neutron movie that
went out of its way to have the
protagonist have to protect a dumb kid
puts the protagonists own dumb kid on a
bus so we don't have to worry about on
the rest of the film
bosses on that bridge the Golden Gate
Bridge is in some sort of danger cliche
San Francisco still hasn't survived the
Birdemic honestly I've seen this fucking
bridge destroyed in so many movies I'd
be surprised to go to San Francisco in
real life and find it actually intact
until Brody is only EOD tech to survive
- train attack I ready yeah mommy's
thinking nature is in our control okay
fine if you want to preach about this
and be the moral center of the movie
that that's fine just know that you're
the dumbass who spent 15 years studying
this creature and thought a bunch of
cables we're gonna contain the thing
when it hatched had no weapons ready to
kill it and basically the Bay Area and
Wayne's the Oakland Raiders haven't even
dreamed of yet oh the pretty girls in
arbitrary peril I am 100% the opposite
of surprised did you just cut away from
the action just as it was getting going
again
goddamn you are the spitting image of my
college ex I tell you what
music commonly associated with 2001 is a
bold choice and the following skydiving
scene is worth talking a send-off for
but why are bullets suddenly effective
was that not even one moment in the
writing of this movie where someone
stopped and said hey are we having the
main character and the monsters
conveniently show up in the same
locations too many times yeah a better
cut over to the boring humans and see
what they're up to I sure didn't want to
see the big monsters fighting after 98
fight list minutes of movie had passed
which one of these assholes was carrying
a fucking ladder like how is only an
hour passed since they started to count
down on the bomb Lots has happened since
then we saw Elizabeth Olsen stay hot
during the preamble to the creature
fight
we saw the Muto's making babies blush
Ford asked about his wife and kid and
FEMA was an asshole like always they
planned the skydiving attempt the moral
center of the movie preached to us the
same thing we learned from Jurassic Park
from Jeff Goldblum and then Elizabeth
Olsen stayin huh just before the
creatures fought each other then the sky
having happened and then more fighting
happened we didn't get to see because
the movies editor hates us and that's an
hour and then cinema sins aren't
assholes hey why didn't Godzilla use
this earlier just like Pacific rims
magic sword seems like it could have
been useful before now I'm wondering if
these army guys are serious with these
guns or is this just something planted
in the movie to make it appear action II
they can stole this boat this is just
some boat on the harbour that they could
carry the bomb - nobody programs into
this thing's autopilot
ya know this is the same issue with
Jurassic park's t-rex and clover fields
Cloverfield you can't just have Godzilla
show up silently like he's a ninja or
sumption also good god Godzilla is
awesome hope future movies include him
the next time rather than giving us what
amounts to 5 minutes of screen time
Godzilla and the protagonist both pass
out at the same time I mean there are
script parallels and then there's this
fucking movie Jesus
are they soulmates are they cosmically
linked somehow how did anyone know he
was on the boat he did that with no one
around and it's the military really
gonna investigate a tour boat drifting
into the water with all the other stuff
they have to do wait did Godzilla wake
up kill them you know then go back to
the exact same place where he collapsed
earlier well on the bright side
San Francisco won't have to rebuild
again until Star Trek into darkness
happens movie expect me to get some kind
of love boner over the reunion of two
characters who had exactly four minutes
of screen time together um sort of not
really
how come Godzilla's appearance out of
the water in Hawaii caused a tsunami but
his entering into the water in San
Francisco and just a little bit of a wig
[Music]
best guess right now is about 40 miners
went down with it
sure they're like three years old - not
- spark
Shanta out of danger
yes don't breathe pepper the needs of
the many outweigh the means of the few
it's just every time I let him in close
he always tries to drag me back and I
can't I can't put our family through
that just what I thought I was out they
[Music]
take a breath okay just listen to
yourself these wild accusations they
could destroy our family
you want answers I think I'm entitled
you want the truth you can't handle the
truth
[Music]
he hid it in one place he knew he could
hide something his ass five long years
he wore this watch up his ass
he died of dysentery